so my wife and I have been married for
over 23 years we've got three adult
children one is married two are off to
college and uh over the last several
years I've had suspicion of multiple
Affairs but she kept my wife kept
telling me Oh it's all in your head it's
in your head well recently I did find
out for as a fact with proof that she
has had an affair with a with a woman
her friend and she has decided to move
out and and abandon us and move out with
her new girlfriend or slash wife okay
how do you go through something like
this and then what what's the next step
when you find out that that that
somebody that you've been with for over
23 years has just thrown that all away
and and not just any throw it away but
throw it away and go live with another
woman I don't want to let
the
who um or e